I want to talk about an interesting
issue with everybody today should
democrats have republicans in their
administration today i'm going to tell
you about what two Democratic candidates
said about this Tulsi Gabbard and Joe
Biden and then I'm going to talk about
the concept of Republicans and
Democratic administrations whether
there's virtue in in some abstract sense
in bipartisanship and lastly I'll tell
you why this is actually a pretty
meaningless promise to even be making so
let's get right into it you all know I
am NOT a supporter of Tulsi Gabbard she
is a soon-to-be former congresswoman
from Hawaii who has missed the majority
of her House votes recently I am
supporting other people in the
Democratic primary not her but she was
asked would you have Republicans and
independents in your hypothetical
administration and she initially said
not only is she open to it she would
commit to it let's check it out
I would make that commitment the the
first and foremost qualification for
those that I would select for service in
my cabinet and in my administration
would be those who are committed to
putting service to the our country and
the American people first we should not
be afraid of diversity of ideas and and
take inspiration from the team of rivals
that Abraham Lincoln - chote chose to
surround himself with and draw strength
from that and being able to deliver that
service and results to the American
people rising above partisan interests
and again putting service to the people
above everything else she is willing to
make a commitment to having Republicans
in her administration now of course this
is always an easier commitment to make
when you have absolutely no shot at
having an administration in which you
would decide about having Republicans or
Democrats but let's take her at her word
except she was asked to confirm oh so
you're committing to Republicans in your
administration she immediately
backtracks and says well I'm committing
not to require that everybody be a
Democrat which is a very different thing
to commit to than having Republicans
this is the second part of the clip
which a lot of people have not seen
I will commit to making sure that there
is no partisan requirement for those who
I choose to serve in my administration
instead looking at that most important
qualification are you someone who is
committed to serving the people of this
country not serving for your own
personal profit or benefit or anything
else and that you've got the experience
to be able to do the job okay
so before we even go further notice that
she inste flips she first says yes
Republicans I would commit to that and
then she's asked so are you you're
committing to Republicans in your
administration she says well I'm
committing not to require everybody be a
Democrat okay cool Tulsi Goodwin now
before we go further
remember that Joe Biden said he would be
open to a Republican running mate but he
can't think of one specifically that
he'd be interested in right now and he
was crushed by some Democrats remember
this clip well I wonder if Joe Biden
would consider choosing a Republican as
a running mate the answer is I would but
no no no no no no no no no look coherent
no I'm serious no here's what I mean
let me finish you know there's some
really decent Republicans that are out
there still now let's think about this
more theoretically and then specifically
this is basically the right answer in
principle right I'm open to anyone who
is the right person regardless of party
if you're asking me are there any
Republicans today in 2020 that I can
think of as running mates I can't think
of one that's actually the right answer
but let's take it a step further there's
nothing inherently good about bipartisan
bipartisanship we wouldn't say imagine
that one party is made up of all white
supremacists we wouldn't say well I want
people from our all parties in my
administration including the white
supremacist party nobody would expect
that now I'm not saying the Republican
Party is all made up of white
supremacists but the point I'm trying to
make is there's not any inherent virtue
in saying we will have people from all
pardis or from all political
perspectives in my administration there
are bad parties there are bad political
perspectives so the first thing I think
is important to understand is that on
the Left we have to be consistent okay
if we like the idea of Tulsi being open
to Republicans in the administration it
should be the same for Joe Biden Joe is
being upfront he says I'm open to it but
I can't think of anybody I get it
there's a difference between a
Republican vice president and a
Republican somewhere else in an
administration but if we like the idea
of Democratic candidates being open to
Republicans and administrations then
we've got to be ok with it no matter who
says it but I don't actually care about
that so specifically the idea of should
Democrats have Republicans in their
administration in theory it's not
controversial we should have the best
group of people to advance a progressive
agenda in total if that includes
strategically selecting some Republicans
to put in some particular positions then
why not we should not ideologically rule
out Republicans with a partisan test but
the reality is that number one for the
most part it's not going to be
Republicans that help us achieve a
progressive agenda so again there's no
particular virtue in saying sure I'll
have Republicans but let me kind of give
you the cheat sheet real quick this
entire question is a meaningless
political game I'll explain to you I
Tulsi didn't say cabinet
she said administration and then she
said well I'm not saying I would have
Republicans I'm saying I wouldn't
require everybody has to be a Democrat
Joe Biden said sure I'd have a
Republican vice president except I can't
actually think of one the number of
people and presidential administrations
is gigantic and it's actually no big
deal to put Republicans in some
positions including the less overtly
political ones and I would go even
further could I find a tolerable
Republican to put in my administration
in a position of some actual power to
appease those who find virtue abstractly
in bipartisanship sure if you said to me
you've got to find some prominent
Republican and put put
him or her in your administration I
could find a role for like Utah senator
and former Massachusetts governor Mitt
Romney based on the things he did
correctly in Massachusetts I could find
something for him to do where he
wouldn't really do any damage and I
could say hey I've got Republicans in my
administration would he be the best
person for whatever position maybe maybe
not but if the point is to find
Republicans to say you have Republicans
in your administration okay I can find
something for them to do the point here
is and the takeaway is this is a
meaningless political game in that it
all comes down to what you mean by
Republicans in your administration I'm
fine with what Tulsi said even though
she walked it back and it doesn't even
really sound like she meant it I'm fine
with what Joe Biden said as long as he
and I agree that in the 2020 Republican
Party I can't think of any prominent
Republican that would be better as a
vice president than someone that we can
actually find choosing from Democrats so
let's not go nuts with the litmus tests
let's not go nuts with the concern
trolling the gasping that Joe Biden is
open to a Republican vice president even
though he can't actually think of one
that Tulsi Gabbard said she would be
open to Republicans in her
administration Biden would obviously
pick a Democrat for vice president if
he's the nominee Tulsi has no shot it's
an interesting theoretical discussion
and that's that there's no particular
virtue and bipartisanship but if you're
trying to check boxes that you have
people from all parties you can do it
safely and without actually putting
Republicans toxic Republicans in
particular in positions where they would
have any serious amount of power or
influence over the policy of your
administration that's all this is